when west side stories ariana debose
stopped by our show she didn't know she
was about to become an academy award
nominee
but we had a feeling take a look at this
extra special moment
in what you portray with anita
your capabilities your dance your fire i
mean rita moreno won the academy award
you deserve it too period
oh my god i'm gonna cry
thank you
oh my god i'm really crying you guys
this is terrible i do because you put
all of that work into it years of effort
and a triple threat there's so much that
you accomplish in this movie it is the
most firing electric performance i have
seen
in my life let alone in the last several
years you are a revelation in this movie
as anita
thank you
thank you
thank you so much i really appreciate it
you know it's it's i don't know i as a
young girl all i really wanted to do was
make movies i found theater first or
perhaps it found me and gave me a home
and then suddenly i got the opportunity
to start making movies and it's
just been a dream come true you know and
all i can say is like just don't give up
on your dreams
because it's
it it will nine times out of ten turn
out so much better than you ever
expected
congratulations ariana it is so well
deserved and we are cheering you on
[Music]